[MUSIC]
Welcome, my name is Jules van Binsbergen
and I'm the Nippon Life professor in
finance at the Wharton School of
the University of Pennsylvania.
>> And I'm Jonathan Berk,
the AP Giannini Professor of Finance
at the Graduate School of
Business at Stanford University.
Welcome to the first episode of our
podcast series, All Else Equal.
The series is about making
good business decisions.
We will talk about how to do it and
why it's so important.
But of course, making good business
decisions is very similar to making good
decisions in general.
And so we hope the principles we learn on
this podcast series will apply in your
personal life as well.
>> Making good decisions
is a very old problem.
And a major breakthrough on how to do it
properly occurred during the enlightenment
with the discovery of
the scientific method.
The scientific method has become so
ingrained that it's hard to imagine
a world without it, many people
would regard it simply as obvious.
Of course, major breakthroughs are often
obvious once they're made, but
discovering them is
an entirely different matter.
The basis of this podcast series is that
good business decision making is very much
like applying the scientific method.
>> So what is the scientific method?
In a nutshell, the scientific method
is evidence-based decision making.
And the main insight of the scientific
method is that you need evidence to
support your theory.
In fact, unless a theory
is supportable by evidence,
what scientists call testable,
it isn't really a theory.
Scientists don't waste time and
effort on theories that are untestable.
>> One other thing that is important from
the business perspective is that we would
like to reject theories and we would like
to reject ideas as quickly as possible.
And the reason why it is important as
a business decision to try to do this,
that we don't want to waste
resources on things that don't work.
And so it's important that we organize
our organizations in such a way that we
give people the opportunity to go
after things and try to reject them.
Now, here's the issue.
For most people,
it feels much better to be proven right
than it feels to be proven wrong.
Now, it's hard to say why that
is because you could say,
if you're proven wrong you've
learned something new, and
shouldn't learning something
new make you feel good?
For some reason for most people,
it doesn't work that way.
It feels that if you're proven wrong,
that you've lost something.
And so for that reason, we need to set
up rules and we need to set up a system,
which is really what
the scientific method did, so
that we can together try
to overcome that flaw.
So in group decision making and making
decisions together, we would like to set
up things in such a way that this human
flaw of not wanting to admit your mistakes
and sticking to your guns is overcome so
that we together can move forward.
>> Yeah, it reminds me of an anecdote
attributed to Alfred Sloan,
the legendary CEO of General Motors.
He was chairing a board meeting where
a major decision was being made.
And he turned around and asked for dissent
on the decision, and nobody dissented.
When that happened, he decided to table
the decision and he said to everybody,
we cannot make a decision of
this magnitude without dissent.
And the key there is,
if you don't try, you can't falsify.
So a common mistake for
people to make is they don't try.
This is a very common mistake
in business organizations.
As the famous physicist Richard Feynman
once said, the first principle
is you must not fool yourself, and
you are the easiest person to fool.
>> And in many organizations,
it's even worse than that.
It is that the organizations sometimes or
maybe even often is set up that
falsifying things is punished.
If you prove something or somebody wrong,
particularly somebody that is higher up in
the organization, it doesn't often
lead to big career successes.
And so one way of improving organizational
structures is to make sure that
if an important idea is
convincingly falsified,
that the people who falsify it
are being rewarded for that.
Now, one way to institutionalize
things is to set up explicitly
what's called Red Teams and Blue Teams.
Where you intentionally assign people
on opposite sides of an argument so
that you try to get all the pros and
cons of the decision out in the open,
so that everybody can hear about them and
trade them off accordingly.
>> In science, one of the best examples
of a cost of trying not to falsify or
worse having an organization
that punishes people for
dissent, that punishes people for
falsifying is Galileo.
Before Galileo's time,
the center of the Renaissance,
the center of
the Enlightenment was in Italy.
And then Galileo came
around with hard evidence,
that the universe does not
revolve around the Earth.
Rather than look at that evidence,
what the Church did was shut him down.
And in shutting him down and in punishing
him, wasn't just they shut him down,
they punished him.
They sent this clear message that they
were not in the falsifiable business.
And the net result was that the
Enlightenment moved to Northern Europe,
outside the purview of
the Catholic Church.
And so all major breakthroughs,
previously was in Italy and
after that, it was not in Italy again.
So the cost to the intellectual
environment in Italy was enormous.
>> Now, and so
the Enlightenment values really
stressed the believe that science and
logic give individuals more knowledge and
understanding then tradition or feelings.
And so in that sense,
it's closely related to rationalism.
So now if you wanted to get some sense of
how successful the scientific method has
been, it is no coincidence that,
if you go back for
as long as we have decent data in
economic growth that say between 1300 and
1800 we had a 500 years spell
of almost no economic growth.
And then in 1800s, suddenly, there was
this explosion of economic growth,
it was almost like a miracle.
And it's not a coincidence that that
moment of economic growth arising
coincides with the introduction
of the scientific
method through enlightenment values.
>> Jules, I think it's hard
not to argue that Google isn't
the most successful
organization of our time.
And I think, looking from the outside,
that success is very largely driven by
the fact that they adopt these principles,
that they have a single focus on
evidence-based decision making.
And essentially, applying the scientific
method to making business decisions.
So we are really happy to have on our
show, the Chief Financial Officer
of Alphabet,
the parent company of Google, Ruth Porat.
Ruth, welcome to our show.
>> I am delighted to be with you,
thanks for having me.
>> Ruth, we are so
excited that you're with us today.
So let me start by
setting the stage a bit.
Right now your company's
stock market capitalization
is close to $2 trillion with cash
holdings close to $140 billion.
Just in 2020, you made $12 billion in
investments in plant, property, and
equipment.
And you've also done some major
acquisitions in the past few years.
One example is Fitbit,
which you acquired for over $2 billion.
These types of investment decisions
are only a small subset of the business
decisions that you need to
make on a regular basis.
So that really brings us to
the main theme of this podcast,
which is how do you make
good business decisions?
And I don't think we could think of a
better guest to kick to podcast off with.
So let me pose this
question directly to you,
how does Google make major business
decisions and what process do you follow?
Maybe you could also comment a bit on
what you would say is Google's biggest
strength in this.
>> Well, I'd say one of the core processes
at Google that I greatly admire is
what we call the OKR process.
On an annual basis, every product area,
every function then rolling up at
the corporate level, we set objectives,
the O, and establish key results, the KR.
And that becomes a heavily discussed,
debated sort of strategic,
set the priorities for the upcoming year.
And the goal with OKRs is one
that they're audacious enough so
that by the end of the year,
you achieve about two thirds of them.
The goal is not to achieve 100%.
The view is if you achieve 100%, you have
not set the goals high enough and then
have very specific metrics that where you
can measure your progress along the way.
And there's quite a bit of debate and
discussion to set what is
that strategic roadmap and
then to roll it up so that there's
a true north for the whole company.
And there's a shared point of
view about what we're doing.
That's the starting point.
>> It sounds to me that this process
is also very data analytical process.
So that raises the question,
how important is data to you?
And how do you deal with people
that would say things like,
I think that decision making
should be done at the gut level?
If it feels right to me, I want to go for
it regardless of what the data says,
how do you respond when people say that?
>> Well you've hit a couple of points that
I think are most important, I've said so
often, anchor everything in data and
the rest will follow.
You absolutely need to have the truth that
comes from the data and the analytics.
I think the biggest mistake is when
people think that because they've
done it before and it worked,
they can operate on gut.
And frankly, I would say if you're
concerned about taking the time to do
the data and the analytics, why?
It should be reinforcing to a decision and
in fact through the OKR process.
And frankly, everything that we do,
it helps lay out what is that roadmap?
What are the metrics and milestones along
the way where you can gauge whether you're
making the progress that you expected?
And if you aren't, maybe the reason
is you need to invest more.
Maybe the reason is that
the idea wasn't as audacious or
well thought out as needed, but
data are as referred the arbiter of truth.
And so A, critically important, I would
say the other elements of your question
that's really important is when you're
thinking about, what are the metrics?
What data do you want?
That is not always as obvious as it seems.
You need to make sure that
the metrics that are being selected
are ones that are driving
the outcome that is desired.
And I think we can all think about
companies over history who've selected
the wrong metrics and
set the wrong northstar.
So that data and
the choice of metrics is key.
>> So Ruth, speaking as a professor, often
people don't like what the data says.
They come in with emotions, they come
in with a set way of doing things.
The data says something different,
and they ignore the data.
How do you deal with that?
>> Well, again, I think one of the really
important elements in data and
analytics is to look at the trends
that come through the data,
I think that what you don't
want is a false precision.
I often say, I don't like the numbers, I
like the trends and I like the sensitivity
analysis because I think it is too easy
to anchor on just a set of numbers.
That in my view is not helpful.
The most important is to look at
what are the trends over time.
And then to your question,
break it down to the sensitivity analysis.
What are the key variables that will drive
behavior one way or another or outcomes?
What must you believe?
And when you lay out in my view
the sensitivity analysis and
you engage in a discussion about
the variables that will drive it,
it makes for a more constructive process.
Coming with just a kind of flat set
of data isn't constructive because
obviously the world in which
we live is not static.
And so there may be some validity
in the point that there's concern
about what a flat set of data tells you.
And hence the importance in
sensitivity analysis and engaging your
business partner, your colleagues
with what do you disagree and why.
And then trying to break
down those elements of it.
But to me the sensitivity analysis is
one of the key tools that we all use.
>> Very nice.
So one of the big theme that we want to
address in this podcast is what
are the most common mistakes that
people make when making decisions?
What do you think those mistakes are and
what can you do about them?
>> Well, you both already hit on the
biggest mistake and I most certainly saw
it as a banker and that's when people
decide that they can go on instinct or
their gut as opposed to data and
analytics.
As I've already said, that really does
not happen with any frequency at Google.
I think the other critical
element is an over reliance on
what I've described as sort of flat data,
not looking at the dynamic nature
of the world in which we operate.
And that's the value of sensitivity
analysis, but it's also the importance of
understanding, when you're living in
a very competitive market as we do,
that any action we take is going to lead
to change in that overall ecosystem,
and trying to think through how
the world will continue to evolve.
And so sort of living in a silo,
living in a cave and
not understanding the dynamic nature
of what one does I think is a key area.
And then I think the third and
it goes to the importance of setting out
goals upfront and having clear metrics and
milestones against which you
measure your performance.
You have to have a way to check along
the way whether things are working, and
you have to admit when it's not.
And I would say that if you
don't have things that fail,
you're either not reaching out high
enough, or you're not being honest enough
with yourself that you're not
doing as well as you expected.
And so there's a whole protocol at Google
around what's called blameless post
mortems.
It's the goal to actually do a root
analysis at the end of something that
hasn't gone as well as you want.
Not blaming anyone assuming that process
actually can lead to bad outcomes.
People have good intent, but
you need the right process.
So what is it that we can learn through
a blameless post mortem, such that next
time you're in a similar situation
you actually have a better outcome?
And I'm very much of the view that one of
the most valuable things each of us brings
is pattern recognition from some of
the toughest things that we've ever gone
through.
But you need to take the time to
deconstruct, what did I learn, what
pattern recognition is important, so that
it sets you up better for the next time.
>> This is an important theme
in this podcast series.
It's very important that
you've made your mistakes.
And so why is that so
hard to do, when obviously,
you learn the most from
when you make a mistake.
I mean, in principle, it should be
easy to admit you make the mistake.
So in that vein,
what mistakes have you made yourself
that you particularly watch out for?
What are you most careful about not doing?
>> I'd like to actually
comment on the first part and
then I will come to the second part.
You're absolutely right that human nature
is it can be hard even when you're trying
to make it safe to say,
something went wrong.
And probably one of the best approaches
I've seen is at X, our moonshot factory,
where they actually celebrate When
they're duplicating something,
because they want to make it safe to
say I tried, I reached, it didn't work.
And if you don't celebrate and
say I learned something from it,
it's going to make it hard for
people to raise their hands.
I created something in finance,
similarly I call it the super duck report,
which is I want people to raise their
hands early when something's not working.
Because my view is that when
we bring people together,
we can solve problems and time is
the one thing you can never get back.
And so you have to find ways
to actually make it fun and
safe to say something seems like
it's not going as well as expected.
So I do think that's a critical area.
To your question, where have I
found that I keep going back to it.
I would say probably the most
important thing as leaders is we need
to have the right organizational
structure and the right people.
>> Yes, absolutely.
And there was something earlier that
you said that I also thought was very
interesting.
Because one thing that we wanted to push
as an idea is that good business decision
making is very much like
the scientific method.
So quickly finding out
what doesn't work so
that everybody can move
forward is very valuable.
We don't want to spend time on hypotheses
that have already been proven wrong
even when people just
want to stick with them.
It's just a waste of time exactly as you
said to time that we will never get back.
And so, Ruth, I have one more question for
you that I would like to
have your thoughts on.
So sometimes people argue with important
decisions that they want to have a red
team and blue team where you intentionally
assign people to take opposing positions.
Have you ever tried this?
Do you think that this is
something that would work well?
Under what conditions do you
think it will work well, and
when do you think it
would not work very well?
>> I actually use that quite often,
I think it's a great idea.
I think that when business leaders are
putting forth the proposal, they're not
putting it forth because they think it's
a bad idea, they think it's a good idea.
So what I want to hear is the what can
go wrong or why would I not do this?
How much consensus was there on the idea?
What were the voices that
were actually questioning it?
And I think there are multiple ways
to get at that kind of debate.
There are plenty of times where I'll say,
I want somebody to take the alternate
view, walk me through it,
why would I not do this?
But I would say that in an even
more basic level in meetings,
I think it's extremely value.
I think a best practice is, when you're
soliciting views around the room,
first of all, have a diverse team
because you'll get a diversity of views.
And it's one of the most potent elements
of looking at how to actually grow
as a team.
Second is start with the most junior
people in the room, you want to make sure
you're hearing the voices of
the most junior people in the room.
They're probably the ones who are most
kind of granular in the data having done
the analysis.
And it can be hard for a junior person to
say I actually am concerned about x, y, or
z when all the senior people have
already said this is fantastic.
So I think there's a process
about how you run the discussion.
And then I do think at times the red team,
blue team, or team white,
team whatever you want to call it,
is super helpful.
So there a lot of elements and
process that I think can enhance
the quality of the debate and the insight.
>> So, Ruth, what I'm hearing from you
is that at Google, you're selected for
people who appreciate the importance
of not being in a set mindset.
Understand that you can be wrong, and
maybe you've done something one way and
theirs might be a better way.
That's not the average person.
How do you maintain this culture?
>> At Google,
I believe there's a culture of humility,
people feel we're never doing enough.
And sometimes that can be kind of wearing,
because there's always a sense
of you're not doing enough.
But in my career,
what I have seen time and
time again is humility drives people to
actually raise the bar on themselves and
on everything they're doing because
their concern is we're not doing enough.
And I saw it with the best bankers,
I see it at Google all the time.
We should be able to do more,
we should explore more,
there are different things
that we can be doing.
I think the key in my career
that I've seen is that
the single best predictor for
failure is hubris.
And it goes to so many of the things
that the two of you have been asking,
which is if you want to default to gut,
you want to default to instinct, you're so
smart you can throw out all the data.
You don't want to engage in the debate,
that's when you need to get concerned.
Because if in fact you approach things
with intellectual curiosity and
humility, and it's about learning so
that you can do even better.
You're going to want every
tool at your disposal, and
you're going to want to be surrounded
by people who challenge you.
And so, I think at the core of it,
it is about who are we individually and
how do we as leaders pull together
a group that where you create
the psychological safety to have
the debate, admit you don't know.
But intellectual curiosity and
humility to me are absolutely
critical if you want to build
a successful high performance team.
>> I couldn't agree more.
The idea of humility, understanding
that you might not know the answer,
that you always need to learn is so
important.
It's one of the reasons Joseph and I were
motivated to create this podcast series.
>> Yeah, well, it's to acknowledge
to be in a leadership position,
say I don't know, for
many people it's hard.
I actually think that
level of openness and
vulnerability actually
build stronger teams.
Your team is want to know
that their voices wanted.
I often tell people, we don't hire super
talented people and not want to hear what
they say, the reason you're at the table
is we want to know what you think.
And so, I think that the leader knows
everything isn't going to get the best
other team and they're not
going to have the best results.
>> Thank you so much,
Ruth, this was just great.
We really appreciate the opportunity
to talk with you today,
it's been a pleasure talking to you.
Thank you so much for finding the time and
sharing your insights with us.
>> Thank you, as well,
I hope see you out the view,
I look forward to staying in touch and
seeing where you go with this.
Thank you, bye bye.
>> Wow, that was such a great interview,
and she had so many good points to make.
Also related to the things that we talk
about are students in class all the time.
Ultimately, this is what this
podcast is going to be all about,
smart thinking, concrete examples,
and great guests.
But more particularly,
it's going to be about making mistakes,
identifying those mistakes, and
understanding why those mistakes were
made to begin with, because that allows
us to learn from those mistakes.
>> But the key insight is unless you're
willing to admit you've made a mistake
in the first place, we can't even begin
the process of learning from our mistakes.
And I think today we saw the importance
of, a, admitting that we make mistakes,
but b, understanding that that is
a difficult process to do, and
then going through that process.
In fact, I would say another way around,
the only way of becoming a better
business decision maker is to be
willing to go through that process.
>> So in our next episode,
we're going to explore a very important
mistake that many people make.
And in the process we will also
explain why we decided to call this
podcast All Else Equal.
Thanks for
listening to the All Else Equal podcast,
please leave us a review
at Apple podcasts.
We love to hear from our listeners.
And be sure to catch our next
episode by subscribing or
following our show wherever
you listen to your podcast.
For more information and episodes,
visit allelseequalpodcast.com or
follow us on LinkedIn.
The All Else Equal podcast
is a joint venture of
Stanford University's Graduate School
of Business and the Wharton School at
the University of Pennsylvania, and
is produced by Podium Podcast Code.
[MUSIC]